lorsqu'on a sorti ce disque et donc on a
commencé à faire un peu de presse tous
les gens journalistes déjà mais bon
alors
voilà quand est-ce que vous vous séparez
quand est-ce que le groupe se dissout on
se dit non non non on vient de faire un
disque super on fait une promo on va
faire des conserves voilà donc je pense
que c'est la presse un peu sensation
qu'il y a on va séparer mais non mais en
passant on leur dit merci pour la
publicité
Black Eyed Peas de la messieurs je suis
heureux d'accueillir le groupe le plus
joué en radio en France en 2004 black
hype please récompensé au Gramm miroirs
récompensé au MTV Music Awards
récompensé au NRJ Music Awards c'est une
musique formidable c'est une musique
globale
alors votre votre musique est un mélange
de votre musique est un mélange de
hip-hop de soldes jazz de musique latino
vous la définiriez comment cette musique
positive
bien ouais
ça c'est des morceaux qui étaient
extraits maintenant vous sortez un
nouvel album qui s'appelle Monkey
Business avec les mêmes influences
j'imagine mais à côté un peu années 80
en plus non
une influence de Bollywood des années 80
de la funk la samba aussi bossa nova
souls
alors il y a plusieurs participations
exceptionnelles sur cet album il y a
Justin Timberlake qui est Sting James
Brown
ça donne l'heure c'est génial et le
premier single extrait de Monkey
Business s'appelle donne funk with my
heart en fait c'est don't fuck with my
heart non
qui veut poser des questions à Black
Eyed Peas tout va bien
bonsoir je voudrais savoir comment vous
êtes rencontré vous quatre alors lui il
vient des Philippines en 89 alors lui il
a été adopté
des Philippines aux États-Unis ensuite
la première personne qui l'a rencontré
c'est moi on a lancé ce groupe
absolument c'est ma mère qui était sa
baby-sitter d'ailleurs ma mère il avait
14 ans moi j'avais 14 ans aussi et donc
on a commencé un groupe ensemble à l'âge
de 15 ans et bon je vous passe les
détails et ensuite il est passé à autre
chose en 95 ensuite lui il nous a
rejoint
bon on était très pauvre à l'époque on
avait pas un rond et on faisait de la
musique tout simplement
et bon je passe le détail là encore
on arrive en 2003 direct 2002 plutôt là
on a rencontré
mondiale on est venu en France ici on
était content
ensuite il y a eu 11 septembre
on voulait continuer notre carrière on
voulait faire de la musique positive on
a fait venir une fille dans le groupe et
puis à ce moment là on connaît
l'histoire voilà merci
une question vient c'est le moment c'est
le moment d'interviewer Black Eyed Peas
c'est le soir
[Applaudissements]
c'est le soir vas-y avec tout le succès
tout ce qui se passe autour de vous vous
arrivez à regarder notre cordiale entre
vous et aussi si vous envisagez pour
certains une carrière solo oui ils vont
travailler en solo je crois voilà la
réponse
moi je veux bien répondre à cette
question là on est vraiment les
meilleurs amis du monde on écrit
ensemble on est toujours ensemble en
voiture on passe du temps ensemble dès
que c'est possible
même si on n'a pas le temps d'aller
dîner bon on sort pour rester ensemble
pour vraiment garder cette amitié entre
nous c'est eux c'est mes frères vous
allez quand même faire des disques solo
malgré tout
des choses sous le nom de Black Eyed
Peas OK
c'est amusant parce que
lorsqu'on a sorti ce disque et donc on a
commencé à faire un peu de presse tout
les gens viennent journalistes mais bon
alors
voilà quand est-ce que vous vous séparez
quand est-ce que le groupe se dissout on
se dit non non non on vient de faire un
disque super on fait une promo on va
faire des concerts voilà donc je pense
que c'est la presse un peu sensation qui
dit on va séparer mais non mais en
passant on leur dit merci pour la
publicité
alors vous êtes vous êtes très positif
en fait dans votre musique effectivement
est-ce que c'est parce que vous avez
connu des problèmes d'alcool de drogue
de dépression qu'aujourd'hui vous
essayez de faire une musique très très
gai très positive comme Laurie
non
moi ma mère
positif pardon et on avait des maires
très forts tous les deux très fortes
il y avait des groupes comme des
lasalship aussi donc ça c'est un petit
peu notre background le break dancing
aussi c'est toute notre histoire ça
étant donné qu'on vient d'un pays comme
le nôtre et ben
on se rend compte qu'on avait la chance
de pouvoir gagner de l'argent pour aider
notre famille et ça c'est quelque chose
qui nous a motivé il y a d'autres gamins
qu'on a vu tomber dans la drogue
justement et moi c'est ça qui me qui
motive d'aider ma famille avec grâce à
la musique vous vous avez beaucoup de
chance votre père était un soldat
américain qui était aux Philippines qui
a fait un enfant avec une femme de
Philippines ensuite vous avez été
recueilli en Amérique vous avez une
maladie des yeux et vous avez été
recueillis en Amérique par quelqu'un qui
s'occupait des fils de j.i des filles de
Ji dates
dont je vous parlais c'est la chance
qu'on m'a donné c'est vraiment très
précieux pour moi
que tu aimes beaucoup
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu